you've been dropping songs i feel like
for the last year so
yeah and they're all on this project but
um not not everyone not everyone
yeah exactly but um but like three or
four of them yeah like three or four of
them um
talk about where you at right now and
why is you know why are we finally
getting
you know td we having to wait for
[ __ ] on tv you know what i'm
saying
yeah it's funny because it's like that's
the mode it's kind of like not
necessarily to make people wait but just
to perfect
hold on dj head's calling me in the
middle of the [ __ ] hey yo i'm doing
an interview with you with carson's
finest why are you always interrupting
my [ __ ]
why are you always interrupting my [ __ ]
because this is life
[ __ ] i need you to be on some put a
shirt on [ __ ] that's what i need you to
be you don't have a shirt on oh
let me hit you back after this buddy
[Laughter]
anyway before dee i i got to answer dj
heads like my wife i got it like
something could be on fire right now
that's my dog that's my dog but yeah um
that's kind of been like the mode is to
just
make sure that we perfect you know what
i mean quality over quantity but
um i also feel like you know the world
being in the state that it was in was
kind of weird too
you know we were supposed to drop um
last year but just uh you know trying to
make sure that everything was right
and then when we were gonna drop this
earlier this year in march
um you know covey hit of course and then
we were gonna drop again when we finally
understood like okay like let's
just do it you know we're going to go in
june and then a lot of the black
black lives matter stuff yeah and people
were passing and we just felt like it
would be disrespectful to you
pushing music at that time um so it was
just like a lot of adjusting you know i
mean in real life and i feel like people
forget sometimes that
because we're tde that like we got to
adjust to like we don't just work on our
own
you know i mean merit or whatever the
case may be so and we respect the things
that's going on but uh
i think we're in a good place now like
the whole label you know what i mean and
i'm proud to be the one to start kicking
it off